all right so today we're going to start
a new chapter on graph limits are so
graph limits is a relatively new subject
in graph theory
so as the name suggests we're looking at
some kind of an analytic limit of graphs
which sounds kind of like a strange idea
because you think of grass as
fundamentally discrete objects but let
me begin with a an example to motivate
at least pure mathematical motivation
for graph limits there are several other
ways you can motivate graph limits
especially coming from more applied
perspectives but let me stick with the
the following story suppose okay so
suppose you lived in you know ancient
Greeks and you only knew rational
numbers you didn't know about real
numbers but you understand perfectly
rational numbers and we wish to maximize
so we wish to minimize the following
polynomial X cubed minus X let's say for
X between 0 and 1 okay so you can do
this and so forth also the Greeks knew
calculus and take the derivative and all
of that ok so you find that well you
have a problem right because we know
right so you're given our advanced state
of mathematics we know that the maximum
third the minimizer is at x equals to 1
over root 3 but that number doesn't
exist in the real numbers so how might
civilization that only knew rational
numbers Express this answer they could
say the minimum occurs not in Q so
there's not
thank you but not minimized by a single
number but by a sequence and this is a
sequence that you know more advanced
civilization with no sequence that
converges to 1 over root 3 but I can
give you the sequence through some other
means and this is you know one of the
ways of defining the complete set of
real numbers for instance but you can
define explicitly a sequence of real
numbers that converges ok but of course
this is all quite cumbersome if you have
to actually write down the sequence of
real numbers to express the sensor it
will be much better if we knew the real
numbers and we do and the real numbers
in some sense I mean you know in a very
rigorous sense is a completion of the
rational numbers that's the story that
we're all familiar with but now let's
think about graphs which are some kind
of a discrete set of objects akin to the
rational numbers and the story now is
about graphs suppose I have a fixed P
between 0 & 1 and the problem now is to
minimize the for cycle density among
graphs with density with edge density P
so this is some kind of optimization
problem so I don't restrict the number
of vertices you can use as many vertices
as you like and I would like to minimize
the force cycle density now we saw a few
lectures ago this inequality that tells
us that so we saw a few lectures ago
that this density is always at least key
to the form okay so in the lecture on
quasi randomness so we saw this
inequality and we also saw that this
minimum is approached by a sequence of
quasi random graphs and in some sense
that's so the answer is P to the fourth
and there's not a specific graph there's
no one graph that minimizes this for
cycle density is minimized by a sequence
and just like in the story with rational
numbers and the real numbers it would be
nice if we didn't have to write out the
answer in this cumbersome you know
sequential way but just have a single
graphical like object that depicts what
the minimizer should be and graph limits
provides a language for us to do this
okay so one of the goals of graph limits
this gives us a single object for this
minimizer instead of taking a sequence
ok so roughly that is the idea that you
have a sequence of graphs and I would
like some analytic object to capture the
behavior of this sequence in the limit
and these graph limits can be written
actually in the fairly concrete form and
so now let me begin with some
definitions the main object that we'll
look at is something called a graph form
so this is so he merges the two word
graph function graph on is by definition
a symmetric measurable function often
denoted by the letter W from the unit
square 2:01 interval and here being
symmetric means that if if you exchange
the two argument variables this function
remains the same okay that's so that's
the definition of a graph on and these
are the objects that will play the role
of limits for sequences of graphs and I
will give you lots of examples in a
second ok so that's the definition this
is the form of the graphing style we'll
be looking at mostly but just to mention
a few remarks that the domain can be
instead any product of any square of a
probability measure space
okay so instead of taking the 0y
interval I could also use any
probability major space so it's only
slightly more general so there are some
general theorems you measure theory that
tells us that in most probability major
spaces if they're nice enough they are
in some sense equivalent no can be
captured by this interval so I don't
want to worry too much about all the
measured wedeck technicalities I think
they're not so important for the
discussion of graph limits but you know
there are some subtle issues like that
just lurking behind but I just don't
want to really talk about it so for the
most part we'll be looking at graph ins
of this form and also the okay so
instead of the domain so they are the
values so instead of 0 my interval you
could also take a more general space for
example the real numbers or even the
complex numbers I'm going to use the
word graphing to reserve this word for
when the values are between 0 and 1 and
if it's a or let me call this just a
kernel although that will now come up so
much okay so when I say graph um I just
mean the values between 0 & 1 although
you know if you do not look up papers in
the literature sometimes they don't use
these works so consistently so be
careful what they mean by a graph on
alright so that's the definition but now
let me give you some examples how do we
think of griffons and what do they have
to do with graphs so if we start with a
graph I want to show you how to turn it
into a graphing so let's start with this
graph which you've seen before this is
the half graph
so from this graph I can label the
vertices and form an adjacency matrix of
this graph where I label the rows and
columns by the vertices and put in zeros
and ones according to whether the edges
are adjacent so that's the adjacency
matrix and now I want you to view this
matrix as a black and white picture so I
think one of these pixelated images
where I turn the once into black boxes
where of course on the blackboard black
is white and white is black so I turn
the ones into black boxes and I leave
the zeros as M key whitespace so I get
this image and I think of this image as
a function and this is a function going
from zero one squared to zero one
interval taking only zero and one values
okay
okay so that's a function on the under
square but now so this is a single graph
or so for any specific graph I can turn
it into a graph on like this we're now
imagine of a sequence of graphs in
particular consider a sequence of half
graphs okay so here is H 3 H n is the
general cough graph and you can imagine
that as n gets large this picture looks
like instead of the staircase you just
have a straight line connecting the two
ends and indeed this function here this
graph on is the limit of the sequence of
1/2 graphs as n goes to infinity so one
way you can think about griffons is you
have a sequence of graphs you look at
their adjacency matrix you view it as a
picture a pixelated image black and
white according to the zeros and ones in
the adjacency matrix and as you you know
take a sequence kind of you make your
eyes a little bit blurry and then you
think about you know what the sequence
of images converges to okay so the
resulting limit is the limit of this
sequence of graphs so that's an informal
explanation so I haven't done anything
precisely and in fact one needs to be
somewhat careful with this depiction
because let me give you another example
suppose I have a sequence of random or
quasi random
with edge density 1/2 so what does this
look like again I have this picture here
and I have a lot of so I have a lot of
but 1/2 of the pixels are black and the
other half pixels are white and you can
thing you know from far away
I cannot distinguish necessarily which
ones your black which ones are white and
in the limit it looks like a grayscale
image with a grayscale being 1/2 density
and indeed it converges to the constant
function 1/2 okay so the limits
represented by this problem up here is
the constant graphing without constant
value P but now let me give you a
different example consider a
checkerboard okay so here's a
checkerboard where I color the squares
according to in this alternating black
and white manner according to a usual
checkerboard and as the number of
squares goes to infinity what should
this converge to oh by the story I just
told you you might think that you know
if you zoom really zoom out everything
looks like density 1/2 and so you might
guess that the image limit is
one half constant but what is this graph
it's a complete bipartite graph it is a
complete bipartite graph between the odd
and even rows and there's a different
way to draw the complete bipartite graph
namely that picture just by permuting
them rows and columns and it's much more
reasonable that this is the limit of the
sequence of complete bipartite graphs
with equal parts so one needs to be very
careful all right so it's not
necessarily an intuitive definition I
mean that's the the idea that you just
know squint your eyes and think about
what the image becomes that works fine
for intuition for some examples but not
for others so we do really need to be
careful in giving a precise definition
and here the rearrangement of rows and
columns needs to be taken care of okay
so let me be more precise starting with
a graph G I can so let me label the
vertices by one through n I can denote
by W sub G this function square phone
obtained by following procedure
first you partition the interval into
intervals of length exactly 1 over N and
you set W of X comma Y to be basically
what happened in the procedure above if
x and y lie in the box
bye-bye cross I sub J then I put in 1 if
I is adjacent to J and 0 otherwise okay
so this picture where we obtained by
taking the adjacency matrix and
transforming it into a pixelated image
what are some of the things that we
would like to do with graph limits or
graphs in general ranges okay so here's
our some quantities we're interested in
when considering graph limits so given
two graphs G and H we say that a graph
homomorphism so a graph homomorphism
between from G to H is a map of their
vertex s
such that the edges are preserved so you
have so whenever you V is an edge inch
their image vertices get mapped to an
edge of G and we are interested in the
number of graph homomorphisms so often I
use uppercase to denote a set so the set
of homomorphisms G to H and lowercase to
denote the number so for example the
number of homomorphisms from a single
vertex so single vertex with no edge to
a graph G that's just the okay what is
this quantity so it's the number of
vertices of G what about homomorphisms
from an edge to G not quite a number of
edges but twice the number of edges okay
what about the number of homomorphisms
from a triangle to G
okay so okay you got the idea so the six
times the number of triangles okay so
now let me ask a slightly more
interesting question what about the
number of homomorphisms from H to a
triangle what's a different name for
this quantity here
it's a number of proper three colorings
number of okay so there's a number of
property coloring the number of proper
colorings of H with three labelled
colors red green and blue so think about
the three vertices as red green and blue
and whichever vertex of H get mapped to
red color that vertex red you see that
there's a one-to-one correspondence
between such homomorphisms and proper
colorings so many important graph
parameters graph quantities can be
encoded in terms of craft hormone
morphisms and these are the ones that
we're going to be looking at most of the
time when we're thinking about very
large graphs often it's not a number of
homomorphisms that concern us but the
density of homomorphisms and the
difference between homomorphisms on one
hand and sub graphs is that
homomorphisms not quite the same as sub
graphs other than this multiplicity
because you might have a non injective
homomorphisms but this non injective
homomorphisms do not end up contributing
very much because they only have an to
the number of vertices of h minus 1 on
that water where i think of n as the
number of vertices of G so and it's
supposed to be large so in terms of
graph limits when n gets large I don't
need to distinguish so much between
homomorphisms and sub graphs we define
the homomorphism density
denoted by the letter T from H to G by
define it to be the fraction of all
vertex maps that are homomorphisms so
this is also equivalent we defined as
the probability that a uniform random
map from the vertex set of H to the
vertex set of G is a homomorphism from H
to G so it's a graph homomorphism and
this quantity turns out to be quite
important so what can be seen this a lot
and because of this remark over here in
the limit this quantity on graph
homomorphism densities in the limit as
the number of vertices G goes to
infinity and H fixed so homomorphism
densities approaches the same limit as
sub graph densities
so you should regard these two
quantities as basically the same thing
any questions so far
all right so all of these quantities so
far defined are for okay so there
everything is defined so far for graphs
right so what happens between graphs and
graphs so what about for griffons now
I'll give you this limit object just
analytic object I can still define
densities by integrals now so suppose I
start with a symmetric measurable
function for example I'll graph on but I
can let my range be even more generous
starting with such a function I define
the graph homomorphism density from a
fixed graph H to this graph on or kernel
more generally to be the following
integral where I'm before I go down the
full form let me first give you an
example I think it will be more helpful
so if I'm looking at a triangle going to
W what I would like is integral that
captures the triangle density so this
quantity here if I let XYZ vary over
zero and one zero to one independent in
uniformly then this quantity here
captures the triangle density in W in
fact and now state status more precisely
in a second if you look at the
translation from graph to graph on and
combine that translation with this
definition here you recover the triangle
density
more generally 4h instead of a triangle
the H density in a graph form is defined
to be the integral of instead of this
product here I take a product
corresponding to the graph structure of
H one factor for each edge of H and the
variables go over the vertex set of H so
this is the definition of homomorphism
densities not for graphs before
symmetric measurable functions in
particular for graph owns and we define
it this way because and we use the same
symbols because these two definitions
agree if you start with a graph and look
at the H density in G then this quantity
here is equal to the H density in the
graph on associated to the graph G
constructed as we did just now okay so
make sure you understand why this is
true and why we defined densities this
way any questions so far
what so we've given the definition of
graph homomorphism density and we've
defined these objects these graphs and I
mentioned even something about the idea
of a limit but in what sense can we have
a limit of graphs so here's an important
definition on the convergence of graphs
so in what sense
can we say that a sequence of graphs
converge so we say that sequence graphs
jiseop n graphs or graph ons so these
two definitions are interchangeable for
the what I'm about to say regarding
limits so phones in which case I'm going
to denote them by W sub M okay so we say
the sequence is convergent if the
sequence of sub graph densities of
course if you're looking at griffons
then you should look at the graph on sub
graph density in homomorphism density in
griffons if this sequence converges and
goes to infinity for every graph
eh okay so that's the definition of what
it means for sequence of graphs to
converge which so far looks actually
quite different from what we discussed
intuitively but I will state some
theorems towards the end of this lecture
explaining what the connections are
alright so intuitively what I've said
earlier is that you have a sequence of
graphs that are convergent if you have
some vague notion of one image morphing
into a sequence of images morphing into
this final image it still hold that
thought in your mind but that's not a
rigorous definition yet the definition
we will use for convergent convergence
is if all the subgraph all the
homomorphism densities or equivalently
subgraph densities they converge so this
is the definition it's not required so
this is basically rigorous as stated
just as a remark it's it's not required
that the number of vertices goes to
infinity although you wouldn't you think
that is the case so just put it out
there something I can have a sequence of
constant graphs and they will still be
convergent and and that's still okay but
you should think of the number of
vertices going to infinity
thank you any other questions
all right so so there are some questions
that would like to discuss right and
this will occupy the next few lectures
in terms of proving the following
statements one is do you always have
graph limits if you have a convergent
sequence of graphs do they always
approach a limit just because something
is convergent doesn't mean you can
represent the limit necessarily okay so
it turns out the answer is yes turns out
that and this is makes it a good theory
a good useful theory or easy theory to
use that there's always a limit object
when whenever you have convergence and
the other question is well we've
described intuitively one notion of
convergence and also defined more
rigorously another this definition of
convergence are these two notions
compatible and what does this even mean
right this idea of image becoming closer
and closer to a final image what does
that even mean okay so these are some of
the questions I would like to address so
in the the next few things I would like
to discuss it first I want to give you a
definition of a distance between two
graphs or two graphs if I give you two
graphs how similar or dissimilar are
they so that we have this metric and
then we can talk about convergence in
metric spaces
let's take quick let's take a quick
break
okay so given this notion of convergence
I would like to define a notion of
distance between graphs so that
convergence corresponds to convergence
in the metric space sense of distance
going to zero so how can we define
distance first let me tell you that
there's a trivial way right so there's a
way which you look at that definition
and produce a distance out and here's
what you can do I can I can convert that
definition to a metric by setting the
distance between two graphs g and g
prime to be the following quantity
obtained by well what would i like to do
i would like to say the distance goes to
zero if and only if that homomorphism
densities they're all close to each
other okay so i can sum up all the
homomorphism densities and look at there
are differences between g and g prime
and i simply enumerate the list of all
possible graphs
I want to be just slightly more careful
with this definition here because I want
something which ok so we write this this
number might be infinite for all pairs G
& G Prime
so if I just add a scaling factor here
then then this is this is some distance
okay so this is some distance and you
see that it matches the definition up
there but it's completely useless right
it might as well might as well not said
anything because it's tautologically the
same as what's happened up there and if
I give you two graphs you know it
doesn't really tell you all that much
information except to encapsulate that
definition into a single number okay so
I'm just the point of this is just just
to tell you that you know there's
there's always a trivial way to define
distance but we want some more
interesting ways okay so what can we do
so here's an attempt which is better
than other distance okay so we've seen
this before when we discuss removal on
us the Edit distance is the number of
edges you need to change to go from one
graph to the other graph and it seems
like a pretty reasonable thing to do and
it is an important quantity for many
applications but turns out not the right
one for our application and here's the
reason okay so this is why the Edit
distance is okay so by the distance I
mean one over the number of vertex
squared times the number of changes
needed okay so there's normalization so
that the distance is always between zero
and one but this is not a very good
notion for the following reason if I
take two copies of the edit when a
random graph GN 1/2 what do you think is
the Edit distance between two such
random graphs
how many edges yep okay okay so yeah so
let me try to rephrase what you're
saying so suppose I have this G and G
prime both sitting on top of the vertex
set and okay so if I'm not allowed to
you know rearrange the vertices how many
exchanges do I need to go from one to
the other I need about one half one half
the time I'm going to have a wrong edge
there now you can make this number just
slightly smaller by permuting the
vertices but actually you will not
improve that much it's still going to be
roughly that edit distance which is
quite large I mean this is almost almost
as large as you can possibly get between
two arbitrary graphs so if we want to
say that random graphs they approach
limit a single limit then this is not a
very good notion because they're quite
far apart for every N okay so this is
the reason why the more obvious
suggestion of an e d distance might not
be such a great idea so what should I
use instead so we should take
inspiration from what we discussed in
plotting randomness yes question okay so
the question is instead of distance only
for two graphs with the same vertex set
let's say yes so we'll see later on you
can also compare graphs with different
number of vertices yeah so hold on to
that thought
so I would like to come up with a notion
of distance between graphs that is
inspired by our discussion of quasi
randomness earlier so think about the
discussion of quasi randomness quasi
random graphs okay in what sense can G
be close to a constant let's say so this
was the this chunk graham wilson theorem
that we proved a few lectures ago so in
what sense can G be close to P and one
of those definitions was discrepancy and
discrepancy says that if the following
quantity is small for all subsets XY
which are subsets of vertices of G okay
so you remember all of you remember this
part the discrepancy hypothesis for
quasi randomness and this is a kind of
definition that we would like to
describe when two graphs are similar to
each other when they are close in this
discrepancy sense so now instead of a
graph and a number what if now I have
two graphs I'll give you two graphs G &
G Prime
and what I would like to say is that if
for now so if they have the same vertex
set
I want to say that they're close if I
have that the number of edges between X
Y and G is very close to the number of
edges between X and Y and G Prime and I
normalize by the number of vertices
squared and it's number of vertices and
I would like to find out the worst
possible scenario
so overall x and y subsets of the vertex
set if this quantity is small
I hope then now would like to say that
gng prime are close to each other so
this is inspired by this discrepancy
notion can you see anything wrong with
this definition here yep so permutations
of vertices so just like in a
checkerboard example we saw earlier you
have two graphs and if they're indeed
labelled graphs in the same labeled
vertex set then this is the definition
more or less use how to find it more
precisely in a second but if their own
labeled vertices we need to possibly
optimize permute over permutations over
rearrangements of vertices
which actually turns out to be quite
subtle so I'm going to give precise
definitions in a second but this one
here yeah so think about permuting
vertices but it's actually been more
subtle than that all right so here are
some actual definitions I'm going to
define this quantity called a cut norm
yeah so this chapter is all going to be
somewhat functional analytic in nature
okay used to the analytic language so
the cut norm of W is defined to be the
following quantity the node by this norm
with a box in the subscript which is
defined to be if I look at this W and I
integrated over a box and I would like
to maximize this quantity here over
choices of boxes SMT there are subsets
of their interval measurable subsets so
choose your so over all possible choices
of measurable subsets s and T if I
integrate W over s cross T what is the
furthest I can get from zero so this is
a definition of cut norm and you can
already see that it has some relations
to what were discuss up there but while
we're talking about norms let me just
mention a few other norms that might
come up later on when we discuss limits
so there will be a lot of norms
throughout so in particular the LP norm
is going to play a frequent role the LP
norm is defined by looking at the pleat
norm of the absolute value integrated
and then raised to 1 over P and
okay so the infinity-norm the our
infinity norm so this is almost but not
quite the same as the soup so almost the
same as the supremum but not quite
because i need to ignore subsets of
measure zero okay so I can write down a
formal definition in a second but I need
to if I change W on the subset of
measure zero I shouldn't change any of
these norms and so the one way to define
this essential supremum it's called an
essential soup is that it is the largest
so it is the smallest lambda such that
smallest number M such that the measure
of the set taking value bigger than M
the set has measure zero so it's the
threshold above which you measure zero
and the l2 norm will play a particularly
special role and for the l2 norm you're
really in a hilbert space in which case
we are going to have inner products and
we denote inner products using the
square using these brackets so
everything's real I don't have to worry
about complex conjugates
alright so comparing with a discussion
up there we see that a sequence of so
sequence GN quasi random graphs has
property that the Associated Guang's
converge to P in the cut more ok for
quasi random graphs there's no issue of
having to do with permutations because
the target is invariant upon
permutations but if I give you two
different graphs then I need to think
about their permutations and to study
permutations of vertices the right way
to do this is to consider measure
preserving transformations so we say
that fee from the interval to the
interval yes is measure preserving first
of all it has to be a measurable map and
everything I'm going to talk about are
measurable so on sometimes I will even
admit mentioning it so it is measure
preserving if for all measurable subsets
a of this interval one has that the
pullback of a
has the same measure as a itself let me
give you an example okay so you have to
be also slightly careful with this
definition if you think about the push
forward that's false it has to be the
pullback so for example in so the map
which sends okay so an easy example the
map which sends X to X plus 1/2 so the
thing about the circle as your as your
space and here I'm just rotating the
circle by 1/2 rotation so it's obviously
a measure preserving I'm not changing
any measures certainly more interesting
example quite a bit more interesting
example is setting X 2 to X this is also
measure preserving and you might be
puzzled for a second why it's measure
preserving because it sounds like it's
dilating everything by a factor of 2 but
if you look at the definition so here's
again not mod 1 if you look at the
definition if you look at let's say a
subset 8 which is like so what should I
so if that if that is my 8 okay so
what's the inverse of a so it's
so the measure is preserved upon this
pullback okay so if you push forward
then you might dilate by a factor of two
but when you pull back the measure gets
preserved so this measure preserving
transformations are going to play the
role of permutations of vertices so it
turns out that these things are actually
really quite subtle technically and I'm
going to as much as I can ignore some of
the major theoretic technicalities but
but they are quite subtle so for example
okay so now let me give you a definition
for the distance between two griffons I
write starting with a major symmetric
measurable function W I so I write W
superscript C to denote the function
obtained by as follows so I think of
this as relabeling the vertices of a
graph and now I define this distance so
this is going to be called a cut
distance between two symmetric
measurable functions U and W to be the
infimum over all major preserving by
directions
okay so this is the definition for the
distance between two graphics take the
optimal in my question tizzy and looking
at if so I haven't told you yet whether
you can take a single one and turns out
that's a subtle issue and generally it
doesn't exist so but I look over all
major preserving by directions feet and
I look at the distance between W and W
optimized over the best possible measure
preserving bisection so this is really a
nymph it's not always a pain and
actually this example here is a great
example for you can create an example
for why infants not always attained from
the discussion over here for example if
if you is the function x times y this is
a graph on X Y and W is you see where Z
is the map that sends X 2 to X then you
know in your mind you should think of
these two as really the same graphics
you're applying the measure preserving
transformation it's like doing a
permutation
but because V is not by ejected you
cannot putting fie here to get these two
things to be the same okay so it's so
there's some subtlety so this is really
an example to just to highlight there's
some subtleties here which I'm gonna try
to ignore as much as possible
and but I always give you correct
definitions any questions
yep
yeah so question do we expect the
contestants between these two to be zero
and the answer is yes so we do expect
them to be zero and that they are zero
that's they are equal to zero I mean let
me just tell you one something that is
known and this is one of those
statements that has a lot of major
theoretic technicalities for all
griffons
U and W it turns out that there exist
major preserving maps okay so not
necessarily by sections but major
preserving maps from zero one interval
to itself such that the distance between
u and W the cut distance is obtained by
the cut norm difference between of the
difference between UV and W sigh
don't worry about it okay so so far
we've defined this notion of a cut
distance between two graph ons but now
I'll give you two graphs so what you do
do for two graphs well I can okay great
so take the graphing associated with
these graphs and consider their cut
distance so for graph G and G prime and
potentially even different number of
vertices I can define the distance the
cut distance between these two graphs to
be the distance between the Associated
graph ohms and similarly if I have a
graph and a graph on I can also compare
their distance
so what does this actually mean alright
so if I give you two graphs even with
the same number of vertices it's not
quite the same thing as a permutation of
vertices it's a bit more subtle why is
it more subtle than just permuting the
vertices so here we're using measure
preserving transformations which doesn't
see your atomic vertices so we might
split up your vertices so you might take
a vertex and then you know chop it in
half and send one half somewhere and
another half somewhere else yes these
guys they don't care about your vertices
anymore so it's not quite the same as
commuting vertices but it's some kind of
fun so you allow some kind of splitting
and rearrangement and overlays so you
can write out this distance in this
format find out the best way to split an
overlay and to rearrange that way but
it's much cleaner to just define it in
terms of graphics yes okay questions is
there why we take my junctions up there
and no so up there if I wrote instead
major preserving Maps it's still a
correct definition and it's the same
definition and the fact that these two
are equivalent goes through some measure
theory which I want I will not do not
want it indulgent
great but the moral of the story is you
take two graphics
I'm rearrange the vertices in some way
in the best way overlaid them on top of
each other and take the difference and
look at a cut norm so that's the
distance all right so I want to finish
by stating the main theorems that formed
graph limit theory and these are
addressed the questions I mentioned
right before the break so do there exist
limits and do these two different
notions of one having to do with
distance and another having to do with
homomorphism densities how do they
relate to each other are they consistent
[Applause]
so first theorem one has to do with the
equivalence of convergence namely that
if you have a sequence of graphs or
graph owns the sequence is convergent in
the sense up there if and only if they
are convergent in the sense of in this
metric space so remember what
convergence means in the metric space is
that of a Cauchy sequence so if and only
if it is a Cauchy sequence with respect
to this cut distance okay so it just
before many of you it's been a while
since you took 18100 so I never remind
you a Cauchy sequence in this case it
means that if I look at the distance
between two graphs a if I look far
enough out then I can contain the rest
of the sequence in an arbitrarily small
ball so super-positive
m of this guy here goes to 0 as n goes
to infinity because we we don't know yet
the whether the limit exists so I can't
talk about them getting closer and
closer to a limit but they mutually get
closer to each other
okay so theorem one tells us that these
two notions one having to do with
homomorphism densities yes
consistent and in fact equivalent to
appropriate notion in the metric space
so now we okay so let's use the symbol
so we say that G sub n converges to W
okay so or in the case of sequence of
graph ons
okay so we can do that as well so if so
here we say that G sub n converges W if
whenever you look at the f density in G
sub n this sequence converges to the
corresponding f density in W for every F
and similarly if you have a graph on
instead of a graph so that definition
will just know whether sequence is
convergent here's it converges to this
graph on W and the question is if you
give me a convergent sequence is there a
limit does it converge to some limit and
the answer is yes and that's the second
theorem which tells us the existence of
the limit object the statement is that
every convergent sequence of graph
or griffons has a limit graph alright so
now I want you to imagine this space of
griffons
so have the space containing or the
Griffons and let me denote this space by
this curly w naught so this not is don't
worry about it is more just convention
but let me also put a tilde on top for
the following reason let this be the
space of graphing x' where we identify
graph owns with distance 0 so then this
space combined with this metric is a
metric space it is the space of graphics
so the third theorem is that it's the
compactness of the space of griffons
namely that this space is compact
okay because we're in the metric space
compactness in the usual sense of every
open cover has a finite sub cover it's
equivalent to slightly more intuitive
notion of sequential compactness every
sequence has a convergent subsequence
and then it's also limit converges to
some limit so how do you how should you
think of theorem 3 so it's about
compactness and you know some
topological notion but intuitively you
should think of compactness saying in
the English word the English meaning of
the word compact is no small if you
think of this space as being quite small
which is rather counterintuitive because
we're looking at the space of griffons
you know certainly at least as large as
the space of graphs but in really all
functions from the square to the
interval which seems like a pretty large
space but this theorem here says that in
fact that space is quite small and we
have we also seen that philosophy before
so in summary this graph regularity
lemma the underlying philosophy there is
that even though the possibilities the
space of possibilities for graph is
quite large
once you apply similarities regularity
lemma and once you are ok with some
epsilon approximations there's only a
small description this bounded
description of a graph and you can work
with that description and these two
philosophies it's non coincidence that
they are consistent with each other
because we will use similarities
regularity lemma to prove this
compactness in fact we will use a
slightly weaker version of similarities
regularity lemma to prove compactness
and then
see that from the compactness one can
use properties of the compactness to
boost to a stronger version of
regularity but the underlying philosophy
here is that this compactness is in some
sense a quantity is a qualitative
reformulation analytic reformulation of
similarities
graph regularity
okay so so this topic this graph limits
which you know well explore for the next
few lectures including giving you a
proof of oh three of these main theorems
nicely encapsulates the past couple of
topics we've done so on one hand
similarities regularity lemma or some
version that will be used in proving the
existence of the element and also the
compactness and also it's
philosophically and in in some sense
related very much equivalent in some
sense and related to these notions
there's also related to quasi randomness
in particular quasi random graphs that
we did a few lectures ago where in quasi
random graphs we are really looking at
the constant graph on in this language
and now we expand our horizons and
instead of just looking at the constant
graph on we can now consider arbitrary
graph phones so there this model for a
very large graph any questions
questions can we prove theorem three
analytically and deduce the regularity
lemma so you'll see once you see the
proof depends on what you mean by
roughly the answer is yes but there's a
very important caveat is that because
we're using compact Ness any argument
involving compactness gives no
quantitative bounds so you will have a
proof of the similarity regularity lemma
that tells you there is a bound for each
epsilon but it doesn't tell you what the
bound is
okay does Cote theorem 3 imply theorem 1
and the answer is no because theorem 1
the notion of convergence is about
homomorphism densities right so the
theorem 1 is about these two different
notions of convergence and that they're
equivalent to each other
theorem 3 is just about the metric it's
about the cut metric so theorem 1 is the
point of theorem 1 is that you have
these two you have these two notions of
convergence 1 having to do with sub
graph densities and the other having to
do with a cut distance and in fact
they're equivalent notions so all great
questions and the others a graph or
graph on F is always a graph so in t f w
it i do not define this quantity for
graph on f so this quantity here i'm
only allow the second argument to be a
graph on the first argument is not
allowed to be a graph on it doesn't make
sense ok questions theorem 1 and theorem
2 together
implied theorem 3 so first of all
theorem 1 is is really it's not about
compactness right so it's really about
the equivalence of two different notions
of convergence it's like you have two
different metrics I'm showing that these
two metrics are equivalent to each other
theorem 2 and theorem 3 are quite
intimately related so theorem 2 is about
I mean they're - okay so they're quite
related but they're not quite the same
so let me just give you the real line
analogy going back to what we said in
the beginning or so theorem 2 is kind of
like saying that the real numbers is
complete so every convergent sequence
has a limit
so where's theorem three is more than
that it's also bounded right in some
sense but here if there's no notion of
bounded it's it's compact so but but the
the main I mean you should think of
these two are very much related to each
other
here it's
but but they're not equivalent anything
else okay great so that's all for today